- Hello, and welcome to Khan Academy's
International Women's Day fireside chat.
I am Rachel Cooke, the
senior communications manager
here at Khan Academy,
and you are in for a treat today
because we have some
amazing conversation on deck
with some two badass tech
chicks from Khan Academy.
Super excited to introduce them
and talk with them today.
I wanted to say hello to our
international team members
in Brazil, Mexico, India, Peru.
Thinking of them, I
think that's it, right?
So hello to all of you
who are watching later on.
Those of you who should
be sleeping, go to sleep.
I wanna let everyone
know that you can submit
your questions on Facebook
if you have questions for
this amazing panel here.
So we're gonna get right started.
To my left, I have May-Li Khoe,
who is our VP of design
here at Khan Academy.
She hails from great companies,
like Apple, and LeapFrog, and IBM.
We also have Marta, oops.
Marta, I always forget
how to say your last name.
Marta Kosarchyn.
- Perfect.
- Who's our VP of engineering.
She hails from HP and Intuit.
And in case you don't know,
Khan Academy is huge,
huge fans of Harry Potter.
So May-Li is representing
House Slytherin today,
and Marta is representing
House Gryffindor.
(audience laughs)
By the end of this chat,
you can guess which house I belong into.
So I'm a really big fan of
sort of classic movies, right?
And one of my favorite
lines comes from Casablanca,
which is like, in all the gin joints,
in all the towns, and all of the world,
you happen to walk into mine.
So ladies, tell me what
brought you to Khan Academy?
- Should I start?
- [Rachel] Yeah, yeah.
- What brought me to Khan Academy?
Well, a long journey of many different,
many different roles and
things through my life.
Khan Academy is, you know,
we've chatted about this,
just kinda I always say it
feels like full circle to me
because I started off studying math
and teaching math, finding
out sort of along the journey
that I enjoyed teaching,
which I didn't think I would
when I was being told that math education
was the only thing I
could do with mathematics
as a girl, back in the day.
And I was just a math major,
so I had to kinda make it anyway
to find out I did enjoy teaching.
Eventually found out I loved programming.
So the story kind of is
I then worked in tech for over 20 years,
and now full circle, I'm
back with Khan Academy,
where I fell in love with
Khan Academy math videos
because I could point to them
and tell my friends, so there's this guy
who can explain all this
way better than I can,
so don't ask me.
- [Rachel] That's very funny.
I remember when I told my mom
I was coming to Khan Academy,
I'm like, so there's this guy,
and she's just like, what?
You're moving to California for who?
And I'm like, no, no, no.
It's Sal Khan, it's
legit, it's totally fine.
(everyone laughing)
All right, all right.
May-Li, go ahead, yeah.
- Yeah, also a long and winding road.
I studied computer science
and electrical engineering
as an undergrad and I
had wanted to study art
as a high school student,
but my parents disapproved,
and I thought at the time
that I needed to do what they said,
so I didn't study art.
I figured I would study engineering
and then go study art and do that later.
But straight out of school,
I insisted on trying to get a design job
straight out of school
with an engineering degree.
So I went to the only company
that let me design
stuff and then build it.
So I could have those sorts of trade-offs
with myself, which is hard.
But so we did that,
and then had a long journey
through other things.
I think LeapFrog was another moment
where I was kind of combining the design,
the engineering, and education.
Went on to Microsoft, Apple,
and while I was working at Apple
on new methods of human input,
I kept on prototyping things
that had to do with learning,
so I was like, let's play with this
fancy new input device for learning.
(Rachel laughs)
And that happened so many times
that after a while I thought,
well, maybe I should
just focus on that part.
- Right, that's amazing.
Yeah, I think, so both of you sort of have
these moments when you
were learning in school,
and you're just like you
had some kind of spark,
something kind of started in you.
And I think Women's History
Month is so important
because we get to kind of look back
at the pioneers and
people who have shaped us
to kind of where we are today.
And so for both of you,
is there a teacher or a pioneer
that particularly has inspired you
to kind of go down this path?
- You start this one.
- Sure, I can.
I'll start this one by, I do wanna think,
somehow I subconsciously
found a lot of female mentors
in the department I was in.
I don't think I realized I
was doing it at the time.
I only realized it in retrospect, like,
wait, how did I wind up with only
female-identified advisors
in this major where,
I mean, oftentimes that is
one in 60 kind of ratios.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- So Patty Maes who was at the Media Lab,
who is at the Media Lab, Karen Sollins,
and Julie Dorsey were all
advisors of mine during that time.
And I think I didn't realize I needed it.
I think at that time I was like,
no, I just got to power through everything
on my own, I don't need any whatevers,
but actually I did and was
clearly reaching out to them.
And then I think I've always been,
I really got into both
programming and design
because I was lucky to get
a Mac when I was a kid.
And Susan Kare's work, obviously,
has always really inspired me.
I think as far as design work,
there was recently a Charles
and Ray Eames exhibit
at the Oakland Museum.
Shout out to Oakland Museum.
- Eames chair.
- Yeah, and Ray Eames' work is
also really inspiring to me.
Also very at the intersection
of science and design--
- And Ray's the woman?
- And Ray is a woman, yes.
(all laughing)
- Important facts.
- Important facts, yeah, we
recently heard somebody say,
yeah, Charles and his brother.
And we're like, no.
- [Rachel] And Marta, any pioneers,
teachers that have inspired you?
- Yeah, well, all of the women pioneers
certainly have inspired me.
Again, sort of I harken
back to studying math first
and just devouring histories
of women mathematicians
because it was so rare.
So that was always super inspirational
because they existed, which was something.
And yeah, Grace Hopper,
certainly is inspirational.
I think the things she accomplished
and also just a lot of her famous quotes,
like, "You don't manage
people, you manage things.
"You lead people."
A lot of things that have
become philosophy for me
as I've grown in leadership roles.
So yeah, there's a lot of inspiration
in the women who have gone before us.
- That's amazing.
We're gonna come back to
your leadership style later,
I promise, good questions.
So I think for anyone
who's probably watching
on Facebook or internet land,
or watching here in the room,
they might look at you and be like,
these two people have it all, right?
They're super smart,
they're super talented,
they're in a dream job,
they're super gorgeous.
Could you tell me of maybe a time
where something like didn't go your way,
and like how did you handle that?
Or maybe like a struggle,
that those of us who are still
struggling can relate to?
Things like that.
- Yeah, for sure.
I think we probably both
have a lot of those stories.
I guess one that's appropriate
to share today would be
I remember the very first time
that I was promoted
into a management role,
a leadership role, a
managing leading people role
as opposed to just an
individual contributor,
and at least three men came up to me
and said, yeah, you got that
job because you're a woman.
- [Rachel] Oh, no.
- Which, as we know, if you're
an underrepresented group
in anything, how frustrating that is
because the truth is
just the opposite, right?
So yeah, hearing those kinds of things
and then saying these are my colleagues
and these are folks
that I have to mobilize
and motivate and keep working with
and stay positive, that's a challenge.
- And so what did you do?
Were you just like, I'm
just gonna show them
how talented, and how amazing,
just gonna do the work,
or did you, what did you do?
- Yeah, you know, fortunately I was able
to just say like, yeah, that's not true.
I got this job because I was
the best person for this job.
And yeah, just kept moving forward.
- [Rachel] Right, hater's gonna hate.
- Yeah.
- [Rachel] And May-Li, what about you?
Tell us like a challenge, a struggle,
that you faced and kind
of how you overcame it.
- Yeah, I was thinking
about that, it was funny.
I think the way that we had talked
a little bit about the
question, being like,
well, when did you not get your way?
And I was talking with my
partner about this last night,
and he said, "Are there times
when you don't get your way?"
(audience laughs)
I was like, yeah.
I think the two things
that came to mind for me
were actually being turned down for jobs.
That definitely hurt.
It's happened a bunch of times,
especially earlier on in my career.
I think there's kind of,
there's a couple things that I do.
One of them was I know
myself well enough by now
to know that I always
look back with gratitude.
So no matter what happens,
I know that I will have
a positive hindsight
and feel like something
happened for a reason.
Whether or not that's actually true,
I mean, I don't know,
but it feels like it happened for a reason
'cause at the end of the day,
I usually wind up being grateful
for the experiences that I do have.
I think another thing has been
just laser focusing on where
I might need to learn something.
And just saying like, okay,
well, were there actually
reasons behind this?
Is there something that
I could have done better?
And making sure as heck
that I've gone and filled those things.
And so in the instances
that I have in mind
of being turned down after an interview
with a team or something,
I know that like several years later,
the people that had doubted me
were coming after me and saying like,
oh, I really need you for this project.
So that was like, okay, well,
I feel like I've filled
whatever that gap was,
or maybe there wasn't a gap,
in which case, it's on them,
and they should just regret not hiring me.
- I kind of feel like both of you
might be like a little bit sort of humbled
about your career and
the challenges you faced.
I don't think anyone sort of imagined
being a woman in tech might be
the easiest thing to do, right?
There's certainly a lot of,
sort of pot holes to
navigate, we'll say that.
So in your career, how have
you navigated those things?
Like how do you sort of keep on the path
that you wanna go on?
Like if you were like,
this is my end goal,
this is where I wanna get to,
and I know that a career is
never just always upwards,
but maybe you had to take some
left turns or some detours.
Can you talk about that, your
overall career experience?
- I feel like it's all
detours all the time.
- For sure, it's a meander.
My career has been a meander
more than a straight path,
and discovery, and learning,
and learning something new about myself,
learning something new
about what I enjoy doing.
You know, we at Khan Academy
really believe in a learning mindset,
and I think that's what
May-Li was talking about.
That's true in whatever
we're trying to learn,
whether it's a subject we're
studying on Khan Academy,
whether it's learning how
to be a better leader,
some aspect of leadership.
And one thing that I think is interesting,
May-Li just wanted to, to
just kinda double-down on,
what a great learner she is.
She's always asking for like,
well, how do you do that?
And can you teach me how to do that?
And one of the things
that I think we both do
is we learn from each other
and from all of our colleagues a lot here,
which is what makes this such
an amazing environment for me.
- [Rachel] For sure.
- Because we just, kind of at that,
you know, we're meta-learning all the time
in every way, yeah.
- For sure, yeah.
All right, yeah, I think
the wonderful thing
about Khan Academy, I think,
is like you have this
really amazing perception
of the organization from the outside.
And then you kind of come in,
you're like, wow, this is really legit.
Like people are always trying to learn
and do better and improve upon themselves
and it's always really amazing to me,
sort of the caliber of human beings
that we have collected here.
And so May-Li, any other war stories
or anything that you'd like to share
from your career experience?
- War stories.
Yeah, I think that some
of what stands out to me
is just being in the environment
with such disproportion.
I had a long time in my career
where I was the only woman
and the only non-white person in the room,
and whenever we had the larger meetings,
it was, again, goes back to almost like
during degree time when
it was 60 men and me,
and just this feeling of
constantly having to prove
that I deserved to be there.
I think some of the coping
mechanisms, just to share,
one of them was I think when I was younger
I tried to blend in and I tried
to tone down my femininity,
and I tried to tone down
anything that made me stand out,
and at some point in time I realized,
and this is also as a designer,
that I should just enjoy
that and play it up.
- [Rachel] Right.
- And so I would go to executive meetings
wearing all of the hardware,
biggest earrings I could
find, tons of rings,
and it was a lot of demos
that seeing my hands
and it was just like, no,
you're going to get used to this.
This is the future,
and we're gonna just style
it up and enjoy ourselves
because I'm not trying to shrink myself.
So that was one.
And then also, just to
be super honest about it,
I think there are times when
just some of the day-to-day difficulties
would be too much and I would go and cry.
I had a place where I went to cry,
and I think that's, you know,
we can talk about it a
little bit more later,
but for me, I think it's
very natural to cry,
and I think it's a natural,
physical, healthy response.
And so now if I have to cry,
I just tell people, look,
water's gonna come on my face,
we're gonna just keep
having this conversation.
Everything is fine.
This is like a natural physical response.
Let's keep talking. (laughs)
- [Rachel] For the record, we're not just
like all sobbing here at Khan Academy
during meetings.
- No, no, no.
- Okay.
- No, this is part
of my answer to the original question.
Although it's fine to cry if you need to.
- I mean, yeah sure, you can cry.
Yeah, I think it's so important
for women especially to sort of understand
amazing benefits of foraging your own path
and being a pioneer in your own field,
wherever that might be, but also there's
like real challenges and struggles
that you have to overcome.
And many of us aren't
given like a guide book
of how to navigate it.
It's kind of all a case by case basis,
and it sounds like both of you
have kind of overcome a lot
of very different things.
And I think, hopefully,
have come out better
on the other side, so
that's very great as well.
And so I guess from that perspective,
what advice would you give to someone
who's coming up in the field now
who is interested in a career in tech,
or interested in being an engineer,
or interested in being
an amazing designer?
Like what advice would
you give them today?
- Yeah, that's a great question,
and often asked question, of course.
And I always answer
sort of the two things,
two pieces of advice that I share.
One is, it's a cliche, but it's true,
you have to be passionate
about what you're doing.
If you really love what you're doing,
if you're passionate
about what you're doing,
it shows in your work.
It leads to success.
And just believing in that
and the fact if I'm passionate about it,
I will get good at this,
even if I'm not good yet,
and just sort of keep going,
to May-Li's point of
learning all the time.
So I think that's important.
And the second point I make
is actually related kind
of to the first point.
I think, for me, I learned
you have to be yourself,
and you alluded to this a little bit
just now, kind of with
style, and it's true.
You have a style and you
can't become someone else.
And I think respecting your style.
I can't tell you how many mentors
or folks have told me to add
a little gravitas to my style.
- [Rachel] Meaning?
- You know, just more,
May-Li's gonna do an enactment for us,
I believe, at the end of this.
- Stay tuned, stay tuned.
- We'll punt.
- We'll punt on that for now.
She's gonna give us a
physical representation.
- I was told in my last job,
like you need to be meaner, like, yeah.
- What?
- That was advice given to me.
Like you need, yeah.
- Yeah, maybe not meaner,
but just maybe more serious and--
- I was told point blank, right.
- Yeah, just kinda.
- We're not gonna.
- Yeah, so you have to be yourself
because otherwise if you're
not your authentic self,
I mean, you're not happy.
And the bottom line is
if you're not happy,
like you're not doing anybody any good.
- [Rachel] Exactly, exactly, yeah.
- So.
- Yeah, I think there's this thing
that I've been telling a lot of people
that when I get this question lately,
and it's about confidence because
I think a lot of people tell me,
I can't do this because I
don't have the confidence.
There's a lot of people really struggling
with confidence and really struggling
with what's called imposter syndrome.
So I have like mixed responses
and the imposter syndrome thing for me
really centers you as the
person having the issue.
Like you are the one
with imposter syndrome,
but it may be that you're
walking through this world
constantly being given
cues from the outside world
that you're not good enough somehow,
and yet, somehow we
like center that on you,
so that's like the reservation
I have about the term.
- [Rachel] Oh, sure.
- Because I think that
it's not just about you,
it's also about what surrounds you.
So there's a dance there.
The confidence thing, the
advice I give people is
if you are a person who loves learning
and loves doing new things,
you're always gonna be pushing yourself
to be at that learning edge,
which means that it's pretty likely
you're gonna be doing something new
that you've not done before.
So it's natural to not necessarily have
all the confidence in the world
because that might actually
be false confidence
because you are doing
something for the first time,
and that's great.
And so I tell people don't
worry about the confidence
as a prerequisite, it's
not a prerequisite.
You just need to be able to focus
on problem solving so hard
that you're not distracted
by your lack of confidence.
- [Rachel] Right, exactly.
- It can just stay there.
You know, take it to tea,
have a little conversation with it.
But just be like you sit right there,
we're gonna get to work
solving this problem,
and you're not gonna stop me, that's it.
- That's really good advice.
That's awesome.
Kind of follow-up question to that is,
when do you both feel powerful,
or how is it that you do feel powerful
and kind of in those moments
that you might be insecure,
or you may not be sure how to do things?
How do you guys feel powerful?
- Well, I believe that we take our power
in just being ourselves, right?
And recognizing thoughts of doubt
as just thoughts.
So I believe in
many Buddhist concepts in that area
and just sort of being present
in the moment of what's actually happening
and realizing that a lot of the framing,
which is where the doubts
or the confidence comes in,
they're just all thoughts.
They're just neural transmissions.
They're just thoughts and they can be
different thoughts at any moment,
and there's only what's really there
and what's happening in the moment.
And I think it's kind of the same thing
May-Li was saying, but it's true, right?
I'm here, I'm focused, I'm
doing something, I'm learning,
and yeah, the rest of it is a framing.
And I could change that
framing at any moment.
I can say, I'm really great
at this, I'm killing it,
or I can doubt myself and say,
oh, I'm really screwing this up.
- [Rachel] Right, the first one's better.
May-Li?
- I feel like it's a bit of a pattern.
There's a book I really
like called Art & Fear,
and what it talks about
is that as an artist
or anybody that's pushing
yourself on your edge,
your bar or your standard for yourself
has continued to rise
because you learn more,
and so you never meet your own standard
because your standard moves
up as your skill moves up.
And so all I've done is basically like,
I have these, I talk
myself out of anything
that might be paralyzing.
I'll be like, okay, well,
have you done something
you don't know how to do before, yes.
Did it come out okay,
yes, it came out okay.
Just like take a deep breath,
count to three, do it anyway. (laughs)
- That's also pretty solid advice, yeah.
I love that.
So we have some really great philosophies,
some Buddhist teachings.
My power move is listening
to our Cardi B tracks.
So you know, different
strokes for different folks.
Whatever works for you.
I love it.
- Musical as hell.
- And I guess kind of
looking back at your career
and sort of where you've come from,
do you think things have changed?
And if so, how might they have changed?
Or if not, how have they not changed?
- Yeah, I feel like
things have changed a lot.
A lot of the conversations
that are happening now openly
were happening behind
closed doors for years.
And I remember, it's
definitely only in this decade
that it feels like they've come out.
Before that, it was see
if there's anybody around
you can talk to, first of all,
which was often not the case.
And if there was, hopping into an office,
closing the door, and being like,
did you see that, is it just me?
And now it doesn't feel like that anymore.
Now it feels like it's
part of the conversation
in the greater world, not
just behind closed doors.
- Yeah, I mean, I agree, for
sure things have changed.
I guess I have a little bit
more sobering perspective.
I don't think they've changed as much
as we'd like for them to have changed,
or we'd like to think they have.
And I think there are pockets of places
where it's wonderful,
like we're here together,
and we think, we hope we're helping
to create an environment
that's a good one,
and a strong one for that kind
of discourse all the time.
I don't know if things have moved, I mean,
there's definitely more conversation,
but I think the powers
that be dig in as well.
So we have a lot more to do.
- [Rachel] Right, that's true.
Perhaps maybe when you
started your career,
how would you think that it
would have changed perhaps?
You know, what were
you thinking, like, oh,
in 10 years, this won't be a problem
because blah, blah, blah.
What kind of was that that you kind of
are maybe a little bit surprised still
that you have to kind of
hit your head against?
- Do you wanna take--
- Yeah, I feel like I would have,
you know, when I look
at just the statistics
of where we've wound
up with representation
across the industry and in academia,
I feel like I would have expected
those needles to have
moved further by now.
But, I mean, I think
we've seen the statistics
of women in computer
science was like at 35%
or something in the '80s,
and it slipped to 12% sometime
in the last couple of years.
So that's just one example.
There's many other examples
of where representation
in Silicon Valley and in our disciplines
is just not representative
of our population.
- [Rachel] Very true, good point, yeah.
- Yeah, similarly I think
I would have thought 20 years ago
that we would have larger representation,
more equal representation
in all kinds of ways,
in an engineering
organization, for example.
So I think the pace has been slower
than maybe we thought, say, 20 years ago
when we saw things changing a little bit.
So yeah, I come back to there's still
a lot of work to do,
so none of us should be
complacent about that.
- [Rachel] That's true.
- You got to always celebrate.
- Still more work to do,
but I think we're all kind of hopeful
of where things are going, I think.
So definitely, the industry's having
a lot of good conversations,
and I think more people trying
to hold them accountable
to sort of be more representative
of the society in which it serves.
So I think that's great.
And Marta, you spoke about earlier
about when you became a manager
and sort of how hard that was
for people who are maybe
a little bit reluctant.
And I can imagine for both of you
that you didn't really have many
female managers or leaders
as you were coming up in this industry.
How is it that you developed
your own leadership style
or management style when perhaps
you didn't have those kind
of role models to go to?
- Yeah, that's a great question
and definitely emphasis
on the word how did you develop it
because it's still a work in progress.
- It's still a work in a progress.
- Still a work in progress
and we're developing all the time, I hope.
But you're right, I mean, it's not like
you could see a cookie
cutter cardboard cutout
and say, yeah, I wanna be like so-and-so
because so-and-so didn't
resemble me in any way.
So yeah, becoming a leader is hard,
stepping into roles of leading
people is incredibly hard.
It looks so much easier than it is.
I mean, that's one of those things
that I think everybody who's
become a first-time manager
or first-time leader thinks like,
oh, I'm gonna have that people part down
'cause I'm a people
person and I love people.
You know, it's everything
else that'll be a struggle,
and I think we all find out, oh boy,
no, is that not the case.
Actually helping my folks grow,
and yet leading and leading from the front
and eventually you learn that's like
you're at the front
for all the hard stuff,
and you're at the back
for all the easy stuff,
and yeah, but it's a work
in progress, for sure.
And seeking out other women from all kinds
of functions, for me, in the working world
has been super helpful when there
weren't role models in
engineering, for example.
I think that's a good strategy.
- Do you have like a managing tip
that you would give someone,
or like something that you learn,
and you're like, oh, this is it.
This is a key to unlocking
management style.
- Are you looking for one
of my mantras, Rachel?
(everyone laughing)
- [Rachel] I am always looking for
one of your Marta mantras, Marta mantras.
We're just gonna do--
- Marta's mantras--
- One of my mantras is no surprises.
That's what I try to teach everyone
is we can deal with anything,
we can fix anything,
we can adjust to anything
and we'll succeed,
just please tell me as soon
as you know about that.
- [Rachel] No surprises,
all right, excellent.
- I think one of the things for me,
and this is something I noticed
when I had a former director
who was surprised when she realized
that she needed to adjust things
so that people didn't have
to fight as hard as she did.
And I think that's one of the things
that it takes an extra step to realize,
like just because I'm here doesn't mean
that everybody else should go through
what I had to go through to get here.
So what is it that I need to change?
And just like putting that
extra layer of thought
on top of things all the time
and double checking everything to say,
okay, am I expecting this
because this is status quo?
Or is this something
that really should shift?
So that's just like an extra
layer on top of everything.
Yeah, it takes like two
layers of thought, yeah.
- [Rachel] Do you have a--
- Constant self-check, yeah.
- And in that self-check,
are you thinking more of like,
I want to sort of make my decision making
and leadership more inclusive?
Or are you thinking I'm,
or are you intentionally trying
to shake up the status quo?
Are you kind of in your
own management role,
are you thinking, I'm
not gonna do it that way
because it shouldn't be done that way?
- Yeah, I think I'm really focused
on trying to build systems so that people
aren't systematically shut out.
So a really simple
example, airtime, right?
Fighting for airtime in a meeting,
that's a thing that oftentimes happens.
And so what we do on the design team
is we will switch to non-synchronous
verbal communication 'cause we use,
we have a lot of remote
people at Khan Academy,
so we use a lot of docs,
design team's using Figma now,
and we use Google Docs,
so sometimes we'll say, you know what?
Let's do a quick brainstorm.
Two minutes, set a timer,
everybody's in the doc dropping ideas.
And what's amazing is
you can see sometimes
like an idea that was typed or added
by somebody who would normally be
a quietest voice, is getting like
a pile of emoji reactions from
everyone else in the team,
but they didn't have to fight
to get that word in edgewise.
Another thing that I
did, especially early on
when I was managing a smaller team
was when there were
really tough trade-offs,
instead of people going in circles
on the conversation, I'd say,
let's just make a pros/cons table,
we're all gonna fill this
table in together quietly
and then we'll look at the
pros and cons together.
So that it doesn't turn to this like,
who's more skilled at debate,
and we're just looking at the
reasons on the page together.
Yeah, stuff like that.
But I would say it's pretty
constant and deliberate,
and so it just takes more brain vitamins.
- Yeah, just to kind of, you know, yeah.
So when May-Li is tired
at the end of the day,
it's because she's been
thinking doubly hard
about leadership.
- Yeah, everything takes
two layers of thought.
- That's right.
- It's like, okay, here's the thing,
now let me do the double check on it.
- Yeah, that sounds great.
I think kind of one of things
that you just said, May-Li,
was about making sure people's
voices are represented.
And, I guess, because you two
are kind of in senior leadership roles,
you often are in meetings or in rooms
where many other employees may not be.
How is it that you are kind of thinking
of those who aren't in the room
when you are in these big meetings?
Like how do you make sure you're bringing
along voices who may not usually be heard?
- Yeah, I mean, that's a great question.
Well, what all need to be aware of,
what I remind myself to
be aware of all the time
is we have constituents,
so to speak, right?
So if I'm in a meeting, I'm
not representing myself,
like 99.9% of the time, right?
And so I'm representing others.
Yeah, I think that that's an important
sort of general consciousness
to take into things,
so that when we discuss things
about our company, for example,
in our senior leadership team meeting,
the lens for us always
is we're representing
our function here, so what
do my folks feel about this?
What would work best for my folks?
What have I heard?
It's a lot about listening.
It's a lot about listening,
which kinda gets back to
the voices not being heard.
There's so much you can pick up
in just watching body
language and watching people,
and you can tell when
somebody has something to say.
I mean, a classic thing that we can do
to help with that is to say,
oh, it looks like maybe
you have something to say.
I mean, and you have to
find out ahead of time
who's comfortable with that and who isn't,
but there are plenty of people
who are comfortable with that,
they just need that extra little push
to be asked to join the conversation.
- Yeah, that last thing
is really important,
I think, because it starts so early.
I've watched this in classrooms too,
who feels like they can speak up
and who doesn't feel
like they can speak up.
And so it isn't enough to just say like,
the door's open, like you
also have to invite people in.
And being mindful of all of that,
being super mindful of my own reactions,
not necessarily expecting somebody
to have a perfectly
formulated thought, coming in.
- [Rachel] Right.
- I've definitely told people like, look,
I just need the data, it's like what
we were talking about earlier,
I just wanna learn so that I can
fix anything that needs fixing,
and I can't do that if
I don't have the data.
And the way that I don't get data
is if I make myself unapproachable,
or if there aren't other,
or whether it's me,
or if there aren't other routes
for that information to get to me.
So sometimes I tell people like, look,
it's okay if you don't have
this thoughtfully formulated,
just tell me what you can,
and I'm gonna help you tease it apart.
- [Rachel] Yeah, that
sounds really great too.
- Yeah.
- And then, I guess,
I'm trying to figure out the best way
to formulate this question, when,
I always feel like when women are in lead
or there are women around,
it is a bit of more inclusive,
it is a more thoughtful
work environment, right?
What is the opposite of that, right?
What are the things you notice
when there are not women in the room?
- Well, we don't talk
about our cute skirt.
(Rachel laughs)
Sometimes.
- I was all like--
- [Rachel] It's a very fashionable skirt.
- I was all like what brand is she using?
(everyone laughing)
- Or the lipstick.
No, I'm kidding.
Do you wanna go first?
Do you have a thought
of what that looks like?
- Yeah.
Kind of, there are two stories.
Like one of them I remember
after being the only woman
in a room for so long in
one of my work environments,
another woman joined and she
just messaged me quietly,
she said, do you have a safety pin?
And I just remember feeling overjoyed
that we could talk about
a safety pin, right?
All of a sudden there was
just this relief like,
oh, you use those too?
- [Rachel] Yeah, yeah.
I love how with the men in the room
are like, safety pin?
But you literally have no idea
how like gold those things are.
Those are money.
- They're amazing.
- [Rachel] To find a safety
pin when you need one
'cause like your blouse just won't button
for some reason, and you're like--
- Or you're--
- Where the hell is that safety pin?
Yeah, exactly, anything, like yeah.
- I think the other
thing I've noticed a lot
is that there's a lack of
physical gesturings of dominance,
and that is something that,
especially if you're new
to like office workforce,
I'll just give you some examples, so say--
- [Rachel] M-L time.
- Say, Marta and I were in a disagreement,
I might like tip my chin up higher
and kind of look down my nose at her.
That's like one way of
exerting physical dominance.
Or I might get a pointy object
and do this type of thing.
Now everybody in the meeting is like
paying more attention to me
because I'm waving this object.
Or I might get up and just
kind of like make myself
as big as possible, put
my hands on my hips,
rock back and forth, or like,
you know, like awkwardly
stand behind her like this
while she's talking just to--
- And why are you
standing behind me, dude?
- Yeah, but this kind of stuff,
like sometimes I will like leave
the confines and like see people
doing that in some other place,
and I'm like, what are you doing?
Like getting up or sitting on the table
to make sure their head is higher.
Like contrast our, I still remember
like when our manager Jenny started,
we were in a meeting with her,
and she sat on the floor,
she was the only person
sitting on the floor,
she sat on the floor and made herself
as small as possible in
this meeting of managers,
and I was like, wow, what a contrast.
- [Rachel] Right.
- 'Cause I was used to
a lot of the punctuating
every point I have to say with a,
you know, like this kind of stuff.
And it was funny 'cause
it worked on people.
So every once in a while,
I felt like I had to do it,
but I don't feel like that here.
- [Rachel] Right, yeah.
- Yeah, for sure.
- [Rachel] Yeah, we don't do that here,
which is really great.
- We definitely don't do that here.
- [Rachel] Shout out to the
good men in Khan Academy,
we don't do that here.
- We don't do that here, it's true.
Not by anyone, but yeah,
I mean, on a more subtle fashion,
there are things, I think,
with women in the room there tends to be
more of the asking others
for their thoughts.
I think just, I do feel naturally
there's often a little more
inclusion just in the room.
- [Rachel] Right.
- And so I think that that's
kind of a characteristic
that is true in a room that's got
a large kind of fraction of women in it.
- That's right, large fractions of women.
Let's see.
Actually, speaking sort of towards the men
of Khan Academy, and
they like all tense up,
I just saw it, I just felt it.
I just felt you all like, what?
What is she gonna say?
(audience laughs)
No, all good things.
Do you feel sort of, I feel like so much
of change is kind of driven
in workplaces by women, right,
and kind of led by women.
Do you feel like it's on
women's shoulders alone
to kind of change work environments?
How is it that we work
with the men in our life
to kind of make things more equitable?
- Yeah, that's a great question,
and of course, it's all
of our responsibility
to make an environment that
is inclusive of everyone.
And there are so many
things that men can do
being in that position that they are.
I admire Andy Murray in the
tennis world, for example,
because he's done so
much for women in tennis.
He broke away the first, kind of,
of the male to say like,
well, why are the women
making so much less
money than the men are?
They're working just as hard, right?
They're playing out here
in the same tournaments.
He hired a woman coach,
first male kind of major winner.
So those kinds of things
make a big difference.
You know, sometimes I
think folks don't realize.
Maybe the message that
I would send to all men
is do it if you can
because you believe in it,
show it because it makes a difference.
- I said that the other side is also true.
There's a real benefit, both to everybody
across the gender spectrum
when we're operating in this
way that's more inclusive.
I mean, I've seen a sigh of relief from,
men on my team join and realize
that we're not doing this dominance game,
and just telling me like,
oh, this is just such
a breath of fresh air
because I've been in
all these environments
where you spend all this
time doing that stuff
instead of just talking about the content.
And so everybody benefits.
I think that's kind of the
curb cut principle of design,
it's like making it better for
groups that are less served,
makes it better ultimately for everybody.
- [Rachel] Yeah, I think
that's very true, right?
I think everyone just kind of wants
to be seen and reflected in their work
and feel that they can
contribute in meaningful ways.
And I think that the fewer barriers
that we can do to do that,
I think, everyone benefits.
The work is better, the people are happy,
you're able to retain your employees
because everyone just really feels
kind of all part of a bigger thing,
which I think is great.
So now, I'm going to
open it up for questions.
If anyone in the audience,
or let me just scroll down
to this thing right here.
(all laughing)
Let me double check.
Okay, I'm sorry.
We have a question here, which is,
I gave a priority to my family in my 20s,
marriage, kids, international relocations,
and my career development
took a back seat.
I worked throughout, but
didn't really progress upward.
It was more outward in
different fields and roles.
I love what I do now and I'm
finally enjoying my work,
even though the path was wayward.
However, I want to progress upward now.
Any advice?
And this is a question from Facebook.
- It's interesting 'cause we both
talked about how, in meandering.
- Not focusing on upward so much,
just sort of meandering
through the outward.
- Yeah, I think to that question,
I think people feel a lot of pressure
to sort of do A plus B equals C,
and that's how I feel successful,
and that's how I build a good life.
And I think part of it is
letting people know that it's okay
that it doesn't look like A plus B plus C.
That it can look like all kinds of things.
- 'Cause the way that I see it is,
the way I see it and I've always seen it
is that you have to decide for yourself
what you revere, like what you look up to.
And that doesn't have to be what
is dictated by a status quo either.
And some of the people
that you most admire
might be somebody who aren't in
some sort of position of leadership.
They might be somebody
who's doing something else
that you find amazing,
and that's totally cool and awesome.
So I just feel like if this person
is interested in getting into management,
then to treat that as a skill
because it's a different skill.
And obviously, managing a
particular area is great,
it's better if you have
craft in that area,
but it is a different
thing to learn altogether.
It's a totally different skillset.
- [Rachel] Right.
- And so treating it that way
and being interested in
that I think helps a lot,
recognizing that it's a totally
different thing to learn.
- Yeah--
- And I don't think of it as up,
I think of it as just, it's another thing.
There's like many paths,
and that's one path.
- Yeah, but to get back to it,
I don't want to sort of poo-poo the fact
that someone wants to grow upward--
- No, that's true.
- So just kind of,
because I know we both kind of think of it
in a similar way that's
a little bit different,
but I think, sure, you have a goal,
and you want to grow kind of upward
in more senior roles, titles, let's say,
I think some ideas are
you find mentors, right?
Sign somebody up who's going to say,
I'll be working with you all the time,
and if that's your goal,
I'm gonna help you.
And they will then take it apart for you,
help you take it apart.
Here are skills, right, that I've observed
when you're telling me,
these are the things we could work on.
So there is a way to get there.
I don't wanna make light of ambition
for anybody because that's yours
and going forward.
So I would say getting help from others
is probably a great tool.
- I think the other
thing that comes to mind
is also like putting
yourself in the shoes,
the empathetic shoes of the
person who would hire you
or the person who would
ask you to do this work
and get an idea of like what
problems are you solving,
like what is it that they're looking for.
So if you have an idea that you're like,
okay, well, I'm at this organization,
there's this spot open,
here's the big problems
that I see right now,
and I would imagine they need me
to jump in and do X, Y, and Z.
Just try and get that vantage point
because then you can start building up
the skill in a really empathic way
that plugs into like your
mentors or whoever it is,
and you can say like, look,
I know that you're probably
facing these challenges, is that correct?
- [Rachel] Right, exactly.
- Okay, cool, so here are the things
that I feel like are additive,
instead of it being sort
of from you outward.
It's kind of like a design problem.
- [Rachel] Yeah, exactly.
- You're like, okay, what
does this person need?
Explicit about saying things like,
okay, look, if this is the total trade-off
and there isn't a right answer,
I'm gonna just say that.
I'm not gonna just pretend that there's
always a direction that I see
because I magically see all
directions of everything.
And then I would just speak to that meta
and say like, I know that's
a style, that's not my style.
And so I think from all sides,
there's kind of an image of
what leadership looks like,
whether you're the person who's accepting
somebody as your leader,
or if you're somebody
who's promoting somebody
into a position of leadership.
And I think it can be hard sometimes
for people to look past that
and see different kinds of cues
for different styles of leaders.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like I said, I would love to ask
the person asking the question
kind of whether they meant
external forces, like what do we think
is going on right in the world today
if a barrier, those kinds of barriers,
or whether we're talking about barriers
that we're in control
of, let's say, ourselves.
So I mean, externally there are barriers
because there are, like, if we say,
tech, for example, at tech
there are just still less women.
- [Rachel] Right.
- So that's a barrier right there.
I'd say that there is
still an overall perception
in the industry that leaders
naturally are not women.
So we have that work to
do, as I mentioned earlier.
So yeah, I would say that there's still
some challenges out there.
I don't know if I could pick one out
and say that's a barrier I recognize.
- And I think it's also like
there's an importance to being systematic
about what criteria actually is,
instead of just going
off of like a feeling.
Like, I don't really feel
like this person is, you know,
it's like, okay, what are the things
that need to be accomplished
and are they happening or not?
I think that would help go a long way
'cause I do hear stories
of people saying like,
oh, we were hiring or we
were considering somebody
for a promotion and not having
those things be clearly spelled out.
- Right, exactly.
Have clear, clear criteria
that can apply to anyone.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Another online question.
Among women who join the tech industry,
60% leave by mid-career,
which is nearly double
the attrition rate for men, hence,
a smaller percentage of women
advance to leadership roles.
What do you think are possible causes
and fixes for this situation?
- Yeah, well, that's a great question.
And it's a very sad statistic,
and I think there is still hostility
in the workplace towards women.
I mean, that's sort of true.
So I think that that is probably
the biggest contributing factor.
I think finding an environment,
like the one that we feel we have here,
super important, right?
Because find a place you can thrive in.
And again, if you're passionate
about doing the work,
then just look for
changing the environment
so it's one that you can thrive in.
And that's sort of the key there,
but yeah, I think that's a sad statistic,
and I think that there's a lot more
that we can do to make sure that we're all
always aware of inclusion,
not just for women, for everybody,
but just all the time kind of listening
and reading those signals
and making sure that
folks aren't dropping out
of this industry because
it needs everybody.
- [Rachel] Right, yeah.
- Yeah, I was thinking about that.
I feel like there's also,
there's still a disproportionate
amount of expectation
of being like a super
woman in your own life.
- [Rachel] Right, yeah.
- Yeah, that feels like
that's still a thing too.
There's like layers of the
onion skin on this one.
It feels like there's internal, external,
like meta, society level.
- [Rachel] Right, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, women are amazing,
but we're still only human sometimes,
and it's okay sometimes
to be mediocre, so.
Okay, those are great questions.
I don't think we have any other.
Oh, we do.
We have a question in the audience.
- [Audience Member] Do
you have a microphone?
Do you want me to just yell it to you?
- Yeah, go ahead, and I'll repeat it.
- [Audience Member] Okay,
so I want to follow up
to the advice about finding a mentor
because it can be very difficult
to find women that are
above you in our industry.
Do you have advice on how to find people
who could be mentors, and then also,
how do you actually approach
them around being a mentor?
- So just to repeat the question
for the live stream, there was like how,
what advice do you have
for kind of finding
a mentor and what steps would you do
in trying to target the
right person for that?
Did I capture, yeah, cool.
- Yeah, that's a great question.
I almost followed up when we were talking
about it earlier, that I
didn't want to sound glib
about when I said find a mentor
because the hard part is doing it, right?
The advice is easy to give.
So the one thing that I wanted to say then
that I thought about that is
ask women that you come across, anywhere.
If you feel like they have things
that they can teach you,
ask them to be your mentor.
I can say that in my career,
I have never said no to somebody
who's asked me to mentor them.
I may have had limited bandwidth at times
and said like, well, this year maybe
I can spend a little time with you,
next year, there will be more.
But I've never said no.
I don't think I'm an anomaly.
I think that it's recognizing,
I think the hard part
may be finding a good fit
because you need to find someone
who you're going to resonate with,
you know, what they're telling you,
not just somebody who's gonna
give you their guide book,
like we said, everybody's
style is different and so on.
But I think you're out and about,
going to talks, going to meet-ups,
when you hear someone who is saying things
that you think resonate with you,
do not hesitate to go up and ask them
if they'll consider a
mentorship opportunity
because usually they'll say yes.
And if when, what's the worst
that can happen if they
don't and they say no?
- I think the other thing is like
where you said the limited bandwidth,
the other thing that really helps
is if you figure out like
how to make it the best use of their time
in a small amount of time.
So if you've done a little
bit of work up front,
and you know what they're about,
what kinds of things interest them,
then you can already sort of resonate
and chat about those things.
And then it kind of goes
back to the empathetic thing,
also kind of get an idea of like what are,
how is this a mutually
beneficial relationship?
That definitely helps too.
I think a lot of what we
stand to learn from mentees
are what kinds of things
are you struggling with
as you're starting out new,
or coming up through different levels.
And like we don't wanna lose touch
with what those experiences are like
because then we can't
effectively create systems
to help support people.
- [Rachel] Right.
- But we need to be able
to have those conversations
in a way that don't feel like, cool,
so what do you wanna
talk about now, right?
'Cause then like, how do
we make this easy to--
- [Rachel] To facilitate?
- To facilitate and plug in, yeah.
- I'm curious to know, both of you
in your senior roles, do you
still have mentors today?
You have people who you talk to as kind
of your either like advice board
or whatever, advisors?
- I don't have a mentor,
I would say, one mentor.
I learn a lot from all
of the women leaders
who are here at Khan Academy,
so I wanna say all the time.
Our senior leadership team has
a lot of women leaders on it,
and I learn a lot from them all the time.
Our COO, Ginny, a woman leader
from whom I've learned a lot.
So I'd say more a transition,
just having a network of
women that you depend on.
So it's not like one
network, but one mentor,
but I think eventually,
hopefully you'll develop,
you'll keep the relationships
with your mentors
and you'll develop a whole network.
And now I have more like wise women,
a network of wise women
to whom I can reach out to
about any particular question
that happens to be one
that they may be particularly
experienced with.
- [Rachel] That's good, yeah.
- I feel like I definitely have, yeah,
I definitely feel like I have mentors.
Whether official relationship or not,
both men and women that I'll reach out to
just via text message
or calls every so often.
I mean, I think per your earlier question,
that's a good thing to call out too
is that some of my male mentors
and allies and friends have been
some of the strongest
support that I've had,
and so it's also good to not forget that
that support can come from anybody,
sometimes in the most unlikely forms.
- Yeah, that's a great call-out too.
I'd say more of my mentors have been men
and probably for obvious reasons,
given the field I'm in,
but yeah, so a mentor can be anyone.
- Can be anyone, all right.
All right, I think that
is the end of our chat.
I wanna thank everyone here
in the Khan Academy office for watching.
Thank you so much, let's give a round
of applause for Martha and May-Li.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Rachel] Thank you for everyone
watching on Facebook and online.
That's the show, goodnight, bye.